- So in addition to
Rob's backstage popcorn,
the brothers have been working
on another exciting venture,
their upcoming residency in Las Vegas.
- Yeah.
(audience cheering)
- I'm so excited to come see this.
Like I said, I loved your show so much
when I saw you at the Bowl.
So I'm so stoked about this.
What's new? What's gonna be happening?
- Well, there's a lot.
I mean, we haven't played a
show since October last year.
And so we're obviously
very excited to get back
on the stage.
And you know, this residency was actually
supposed to happen pre
COVID and then COVID hits.
So this is a long time overdue for us
to bring an exciting show
to our fans in Vegas.
And you know, it's a
great town for live music
and I just can't wait to
get out there and play.
- Yeah.
(audience cheering)
- Oh my God. So it's supposed
to happen a long time ago.
- Yeah.
- Oh man.
- Maybe some special guests.
Maybe, hey, you show up.
- That's exciting. Don't
invite me, mama will show up.
- Kevin just volunteered
you to join us on stage.
- Yeah.
(Kelly laughs)
- This is how things get done.
- Kelly Clarkson's gonna
performing with us every night.
- I will just show up. I'm
just gonna show up singing.
I hear that you're back
in the studio though,
so I'm excited about that.
- Yeah.
- I love your record.
(audience cheering)
- When we're back in the studio,
we're writing, recording,
and getting that process started,
and finding inspiration everywhere.
So we're ready to get it
out there for the world,
hopefully by the end of
this year, we'll see.
(audience cheering)
That's so exciting.
- I love it. Look at him
looking at them like.
Right?
(Kelly and Nick laughs)